I'm doing some surveillance
on a slaughter farm
Miami, Florida.
On this farm they're
killing with sledgehammers,
and butchering alive.
I think one of them saw me in the area,
They patrol this area on ATVs.
Threats have been made for
the past 13 years on my life.
I'm not too popular in these areas.
When they weren't chasing
me with sledgehammers
and axes, I would be getting phone calls,
I would be getting emails,
I would be getting
messages on social media.
An undercover operation
sheds light into the
cruel treatment of animals
at a West Palm Beach farm.
The animals behind us residing
in this torture operation
have a voice today.
When people would be arrested
in interrogation rooms,
they would tell law
enforcement that guy, Kudo,
had better watch his ass
because there are bounties
on this guy's head.
He's the only one taking
this industry down
and no one wants that
person breathing anymore.
So Richard Kudo is an interesting guy
to say the least.
So right now, we are in Area 97.
We're just going over some mappings
of some slaughter farms
and animal fighting farms.
He sailed on the America's cup team
like extreme sports guy.
He was also a property flipper
in Miami, in South beach
in the 2000s when the
market was quite high.
And it's where I blossomed financially.
It's where I made my money
and made my nest egg.
But I had a void.
I had a void of doing something
more important with my life.
So Kudo was volunteering
with the SPCA back in 2008.
Basically mucking stalls,
doing whatever work they
needed around the barn.
And they got a distress
call one day from the police
because SPCA would often help relocate
animals that the police
would find in distress.
So, you know, I went out
there driving my Range Rover
leaving South beach.
And they came across some butchers farm
that the police were at.
They came across this
horse, beautiful horse
brown with white on his nose.
He had a broken leg, he was emaciated.
And I walked up to him and he put his head
in my arms and he just
put all his weight on me.
And right then and there, I
started falling for this animal
But underneath the horses lip
on its gums was tattooed a code.
And they were kind of curious
to know what that meant.
It turns out that these
horses are tattooed
on their lips to show where they're from
and what their pedigree
is and they belong to.
And so this horse, this horse
is named Freedom's Flight.
The horse had broken
its leg during a race.
So I tracked his lineage
and it was shocking
that I learned of his
bloodlines, that it came
from some of the most famous
race horses on the planet.
How could this horse end up
at an illegal slaughterhouse?
It boggled my mind.
He ended up adopting him.
Freedom Flight still lives
at his compound in Florida.
Sort of got him going into this world
of underground horse butchering.
These are slaughter horses here.
And we have a mayor down here.
She's clinging to life right now.
The SPCA was not an
organization that was geared
towards me or anyone else going undercover
and investigating these people, which is
the only reason why I started
the animal recovery mission.
The animal recovery mission
taped and exposed the property
while conducting an investigation.
We basically go undercover
where no one else will.
And the public sector
and the private sector,
if they're disregarding something
as far as animal cruelty
ARM will take it on.
It's something that is
so incredibly important
and it's become my life's mission.
He's so skinny.
I would just cut checks and
rip out my bank accounts
to fund it without thinking about it.
The guy right here, his
wife who sort of up.
And to be honest I don't
know how much money
that I've spent, but it's
close to the seven figures over
and
it's been worth it.
I'm dealing with the USDA
right now on a horse meat buy.
Basically they're embedded
with some horse killers.
So horse meat internationally
is a pretty commonly
eaten food, not on the
level of beef or pork
but it's popular in a
lot of cultures in Japan,
central Asia, France, and in Cuba.
And a lot of Cuban-Americans
live in South Florida.
And many of them still
want to eat horse meat.
They're eating horse meat
for medical purposes.
They think that it cures blood disorders
that it helps with side
effects from chemotherapy.
But all horse meat, whether it's imported
or horses are slaughtered and butchered
in this country for human
consumption, it's illegal.
This is roughly 30 pounds
of horse meat purchased
in Palm beach County.
They've actually cut this horse meat
into small steak-like filets.
In Florida, the problem is that many times
laws geared towards protecting
animals are not being upheld
by law enforcement,
prosecutors, judges, and juries.
And that's extremely,
extremely frustrating.
The laws in Florida are still too weak.
If you are a first time
felony animal abuser
it is unlikely that you
will get prison time.
You may get County jail time
but that even would be
in some cases, a stretch.
There's really not a whole
lot I can do with them
whether they plead guilty
or they're found guilty
because most judges, even
in the most horrible crimes
do not put them in jail
will not put them in prison.
So they're placed on probation.
Animal abuse here is so under reported
because there simply are not the resources
for the police departments,
the Sheriff's department,
animal care and control to go out
and really investigate these crimes.
Right now I'm in the C-9 Basin
a really nasty property
with four completely emaciated horses.
The C-9 Basin is this patch of brushy land
wedged between Miami and the Everglades.
And it's really meant to be
an ecological buffer zone.
It's not really meant to
have humans living there
but lots of people do live there.
There are the horses.
This is the kill area here.
That's the rug that they're
covering the horses with
after they remove the meat.
When I first started
investigating the basin
at the beginning of 2009,
law enforcement wouldn't
even go into the basin
no one would go into the
basin and uphold laws.
Certainly wouldn't go in
there to investigate crimes
against animals, which was
why horse meat was flourishing
as an industry.
This area is pretty lawless.
A local paper in Miami
called it the closest thing
America has to a wild West outpost
and having been there a couple of times
I can attest to that being true.
And then people's pet
horses start being stolen.
Usually someone's pet horse, their pony,
they'll come to the barn in the morning
and either the horse has vanished
or a couple of hundred yards
away and a trail of blood away
there's a perfectly butchered
and filleted carcass
of what used to be your pet pony.
When was my horse
stolen, he was butchered.
He was tied into a palm tree.
So all these are bloodstains here?
Yeah.
When I started going in
to the basin in 2009,
I was still a developer, but
I knew hundreds of thousands
of animals were in there being brutalized
with everyone ignoring
the crimes against them.
Animals were killed in
really inhumane ways,
being stabbed in the chest or
shot with low caliber guns,
their throat sled and
tortured, boiled alive,
really horrific stuff.
And to see his videos,
he has a massive trove
of undercover videos
is pretty scary stuff.
So this is Kudo Thawn.
I am investigating an
illegal slaughter farm.
I didn't know what I was doing,
completely and utterly untrained.
I am armed but I still
don't feel that safe.
And I started to infiltrate properties.
Some of them legally,
some of them illegally.
And I started to document the
crimes against the animals.
See a horse. Doesn't look
like he's in great shape.
Before he got involved,
there really wasn't a lot
of policing of this world.
The police down there
have a lot on their plates
in terms of the murder and
robbery and credit card fraud.
And so animal cruelty was not really high
on their list of priorities.
I think that when you have
a state where animal cruelty
is way too prevalent, and
our laws are way too weak,
it's important to have someone
like Richard Kudo out there.
He's someone who's a true
believer, who takes risks
and sometimes crossing the
line to get these secret videos
out to the public.
I understand his passion behind it
but the way he goes
about it, is not the way
one should go about it if
you're going to successfully
prosecute these animal cruelty cases.
I investigated the C-9
Basin for roughly six months
and I comprised files of
roughly a hundred properties,
illegal properties, and I
presented it to law enforcement
but I also collected
violations, building violations,
zoning violations,
environmental violations
while I was collecting
crimes against animals.
Just come out of this one farm now.
And after roughly six months
of just about every night
infiltrating every single
property that I possibly
could in the basin, I created a report.
And the police, they're shocked
by what's going on in the Basin
not only from an animal rights perspective
but also from a zoning
and codes perspective.
And the investigation
of the C-9 Basin actually
led to Operation Restore.
And it was one of the largest operations
in history of the state of Florida.
Thousands of agents
tactically hitting the entire C-9 Basin
Just after dawn
an army of regulators and police
deployed to shut down slaughter farms.
It was just a massive take-down
of illegal activity that was
going on in the C-9 Basin.
17 cockfighting rings, over
400 illegal structures.
You know, hundreds of citations issued
for dumping and butchering
an animal cruelty.
It was the most incredible
thing that I had ever seen.
And all of those nights
infiltrating these properties,
all of those nights,
being chased with machetes
and axes, the danger that I put myself in,
it paid off.
So after the raid, governor Charlie Crist
signs a law that basically
increases penalties
for slaughtering horses.
And to Kudo, this seems like it should be
the end of the story, a sort of climax
and it's actually the end
of act one in the story.
So kudos on a high,
you can almost hear
the happy music playing
as he's awarded citizen of the
year by the Miami new times
but he starts becoming more paranoid
about the enemies that he's making.
Butchers do not like him,
they have followed him,
they have shot at him.
Kill buyers, people all over the country
who are buying horses to
export for meat don't like him.
And so his paranoia was
actually quite justified.
All these mofos know who
I am and what I look like
and they don't like me.
There was one year
I believe I moved close
to seven different times
because they were finding
my address in utilities.
When I would put my name
under an electric bill or a cable bill
The police, and the local
authorities were kind of like,
"All right, we've made some arrests.
We did some enforcement. Let's
move on to other topics."
Whereas he wasn't able to let it go.
I wasn't looking in the
past, in my accomplishments
I was looking at the future of
what still needed to be done.
So after the raid he begins fundraising
quite aggressively.
And in addition to being very good
at garnering media attention
he's very good at
opening people's wallets.
And he goes from 100,000 to 200,000
to 500,000 to several
million dollars a year
in annual income from donations.
Undercover video of
animal cruelty captured
at a popular farm in Northwest
Indiana is under review.
He starts doing undercover operations
in Indiana and other states, abroad
and in Asia, looking at
animal cruelty there.
Greetings from Bangladesh.
And the vision is that
from the springboard
of the C-9 basin, he catapults
into much larger operations.
But what he doesn't realize
is that the C-9 basin story
is not finished at all.
We went to the C-9 Basin at Christmas time
two years ago
and we saw a blacked out fence
and heard animals screaming
and knew that that was slaughter house
so we walked in.
And sure enough, they were
butchering every animal
you could imagine alive.
Goats, sheep, pigs, birds.
So we started to buy at
pigs and goats for meat
for human consumption.
Then we started purchasing horse meat.
And this took back and forth.
We're talking two years.
This is a long investigation
called Operation Genesis.
They start building a case file
against the owner of the farm.
Oh yeah. There it is.
It's a little chop it up,
put in these bags.
And in November, 2020, Kudo
invited me down to Florida
to be part of the raid
on the slaughter house.
Last night, the department
of health announced
that there were two
presumptive positive cases
of Corona virus disease
in the state of Florida.
So the pandemic hit in March
about a week after I was
in South Florida with Kudo.
And this really put a hamper on his plans.
I had to pull my investigators
out of the field.
Months and months later,
we went back and forth with
emails with law enforcement.
And I got a very bad
feeling that law enforcement
did not want this case for some reason.
The plan was basically
kind of a hail Mary.
They were going to go
under cover that morning,
bring some evidence out and then call 911.
We called 911, law enforcement responded
and gave excuses on why
they couldn't make arrests.
The police immediately knew who Kudo was.
You could see how
annoyed they were at him.
And you could see that they
really didn't want to be there.
So they wrote up some
notes, they open a case file
and they basically told us to get lost.
When it's disregarded,
you throw up your hands,
you let out a sigh, you're
you're so disheartened,
you question your tactics.
Should I have brought this case
to law enforcement to begin with?
I think someone who's out
there to hold accountable
the worst of the animal
abusers is a good thing.
It's just that sometimes
we can't use his evidence
because it doesn't meet the standards
of admissibility in a courtroom.
You cannot just go in and
film people or record people.
We do have laws on that.
No matter what you see, what you hear
you cannot as a private
citizen, film people,
record people without their
consent in the state of Florida.
And you cannot continually
go in and have them
slaughter an animal in front of you
just so you can film what they're doing.
Over the years over the last decade,
their patience has grown increasingly thin
to the point where now,
they say they want to work with him
but they give very little indication
that that's actually true.
It seems like they really
would like him to go away.
You question everything about yourself.
about your organization.
Are you really making an impact?
Are you really helping animals?
I created ARM to create
change no matter what.
I'm not here to make
friends with prosecutors,
or law enforcement or anyone else.
I'm just here to help
animals and that's it.
That's the difference
between being an activist
and a prosecutor.
Being an activist is to make a point
and being a prosecutor is to do justice.
And you can only do justice
within the confines of the
courtroom with rules of evidence.
So I guess you have to ask yourself
do you want to make a point
or do you want to make a difference?
Working with law enforcement
and government has very
little meaning to me.
My main goal in ARM now is to educate.
At times even change diets
because if people didn't eat meat,
then there wouldn't be these markets
for me to investigate.
They would not exist.
I will never ever give up.
I strive to make change
and to help animals
and live a good, decent,
ethical life for them.